This is the most requested video on my channel.
And why wouldn't it be? In this video we're talking about the one thing 90% of people can't get right.
Music.
YouTubers and editors struggle to find the perfect music,
because choosing music doesn't just mean grabbing whatever sounds cool and dropping it under your video.
Apart from that,
Apart from that, in this video I'm going to give you 10 points nobody will tell you even in a paid course.
Come on, music isn't even that important, somebody tell him.
It is important. That's how important music is: put good music on even a plain, ordinary edit and the video still becomes engaging.
But even after
But even after insanely good editing, if the music isn't good, it just doesn't land.
So the first question in your head will be, where do I get the music? For that, I've already covered paid, free and copyright-free resources in a whole
separate video.
So in this video we're not doing resources,
So in this video we're not doing resources, we're going to understand the concept of music.
I'm an editor, not a musician. You're not even a decent editor.
I'll tell you things you probably won't find anywhere else,
I'll tell you things you probably won't find anywhere else, because I discovered them myself over six years of video editing experience.
So let's start with how to select the music.
You click it and it gets selected,
You click it and it gets selected. Don't you know how to use a computer?
I'm talking about choosing which track to actually put in the video.
For that, the first thing you need to understand is what your video's emotion and pace are like.
Which music goes with which emotion,
Which music goes with which emotion, here's a list for that.
Now if you just hunt for music randomly, you'll waste a ton of time.
Instead, you should focus on these three parameters:
BPM, instruments and vibe.
So first up is BPM, that is, beats per minute.
For example, if your music is 60 BPM, that means 60 beats per minute,
which is one beat every second.
But what's the use of that? The higher the BPM, the faster and more energetic your music feels. So if you're talking fast in the video, a high BPM will feel
good, and if you're talking slowly, low BPM music will suit it better. Don't flip the two around, the video will feel really odd. So I
You'll only figure it out by doing it, but here's what not to do. I don't want to watch your video, this is getting to be too much. If you do this: [unclear]
you liked a track, downloaded it, put it under the video, but it isn't going with the video, so you go back again and
How's this instrument? Okay, how about this one? And this one?
Here, take this and get lost. If you won't take money, fine. I mean, you're offering so sincerely, I'll keep it. Yes, yes, you tell me, tell me, the in- [unclear]
-strument, tell me. Yeah. So think of it like this: if you want a suspense or tension vibe, then a violin
So you can search for music by instrument too. I just go into Epidemic Sound, apply the instrument filter, and pick the music right from
there.
Then comes the fourth point, mood and vibe. How do you figure out what your video's vibe is?
You don't figure out the vibe,
You don't figure out the vibe, you create the vibe.
As an editor, you're the one with that power,
you get to decide the video's vibe or mood.
Whether you want to give a serious, mysterious feel,
or some funky, fun vibe,
it's all controlled
it's all controlled by the music.
In software like Epidemic Sound you even get this feature,
where you can search for music by vibe or by mood.
And right next to it you'll see another option:
vocals versus instrumental.
If you're showing an epic montage or an inspiring journey, tracks with vocals will suit it much better and make a much bigger
impact.
Hey, what are you doing? I was giving an example. Just sit quietly.
So the rule for this is really simple:
So the rule for this is really simple. Wherever your own voice isn't there, using music with vocals works better. But where your own voice is there,
putting a vocal track behind it can create a bit of a conflict, and the music
you have to use it. Come on, shake hands, let it go, you'll have to put in the effort. [unclear]
Whatever tracks you're liking, you can hit like and save them,
so they come in handy later. And you get all of this free for a month if you sign up through my link, the link is in the description. After that, the next prob-
-lem that comes up is audio levels. In some places the music is so loud that your voice
gets lost in the middle of it. Simple, there's nothing to complicate here. If it's rock music with loud guitars, I prefer to keep it down to around minus 30 decibels.
The next mistake people make is that their music
The next mistake people make is that their music just keeps running through the entire video.
Yeah, so what? Nothing's going to happen, let the music run. [unclear]
Okay, that one was actually good.
But it's important to give the music some rest,
meaning, you should know when to stop the music.
If you want to put emphasis on something, or you're saying something serious,
cutting the music there sends all the focus onto your voice.
And whenever you do stop the music, stop it on a peak point in the audio.
You can see this in the waveform: wherever you see a peak, cut the music there.
It feels really smooth, it doesn't feel sudden.
I usually change the music
I usually change the music whenever the section changes, and moving from one track to another is a bit tricky.
On Epidemic Sound you can use 'find similar' to find a track with a similar beat or vibe and drop that in.
That makes the music transition feel really smooth. But if the vibe has changed, or you can't find a track with a similar vibe,
then stop the first track, put in a riser sound, and start the second track at the end of it.
But if there's already a riser at the start of the music, well, that's where beat sync comes in.
Whenever you're starting a new section,
Whenever you're starting a new section, try to make the opening beat of your music line up with that section. Every
track has a little warm-up at the start, ignore that and start straight from the main beat. One more thing I do is, even when my
B-rolls are running, I cut them to my own
it creates a vibe, it creates a whole flow.
Now everything I've told you so far is just my six years of hit and trial experience.
Who did you hit?
And if you still have the question, why do all this for music, why give music so much time?
So I read a quote somewhere,
So I read a quote somewhere: where words fail, music speaks.
'I read a quote.' A coat is worn, not read. Does he even know anything?
Bro, why don't you do one thing? What?
I mean,
Bro, why don't you do one thing? What? I mean, I know you're really busy. Yeah, I am. Still, take out a little time and come lie under my car some-
-time?
Should I come right now?
It takes real effort to make a video, so please like, share and subscribe. Let's set a goal of two likes. I'll see you in the next video, till then, ta-ta, bye
-bye.